Carter pages done the receiving end of
all this for years now and he joins us
tonight
Carter Paige thank you for joining us
thanks for having me Tom so let's go
back on the timeline to the letter that
you sent to Jim Comey then director of
the FBI about the leaks against you what
were those leaks well that I sent that
on Sunday September 25th 2016 two days
before that on the Friday the September
23rd there was a big defamatory article
put out by a Yahoo News and you know as
we subsequently learned from the House
Intelligence memos that was part of the
this fake news article was actually used
as part of the FISA application so
completely outrageous Carter I'm having
a little trouble with my audio I'm
pretty certain that our audience can
hear you just fine so just clarify for
us the the basics here you have not
after all of this and you've been under
surveillance in effect under
investigation for years now
you haven't been charged with anything
do you expect that you're going to be
charged with anything after all of this
Tucker I couldn't even imagine anything
that I could potentially be charged with
it's just you know particularly after
seeing John Solomon's article today it
just becomes you know the whole you know
that using the term from that quote you
had pretext the pretext was absolutely
outrageous ridiculous and so you know
this is pretext wrapped upon pretext
it's it's completely out of control so I
can't even imagine what I would be
charged with do you know after again all
of this what exactly the suspected crime
was you were the subject of a FISA
warrant the federal government turning
is awesome surveillance powers on you
it's a big deal we have a whole court
system designed to keep that from being
abused why would the federal government
want to read your
emails in spy on you in ways we may not
even know about what what did they think
you were doing exactly well I think as
we learned with the first inspector
general report from a couple weeks ago I
call it inspector IG report 1.0 you know
there's a lot of political motivations
behind what what was happening earlier
in the presidential election campaigns
and I think what is a lot of evidence
that has come out both from House
Intelligence Committee Senate Judiciary
Committee House Judiciary as well as
others there was a lot of abuses going
on so you know I think it's completely
political there's nothing substant to
this substantive to this whatsoever well
presumably if there were something
substance if you'd be charged with the
felony right so this is not the behavior
of a free country of an open legitimate
government spying on its own citizens
for political reasons what does this
cost you financially Tucker I'm not you
know it's like President Trump said
during the campaign it's not about me
it's about us I'm not concerned you know
it's cost me tremendously it's cost many
people in the Trump movement you know
the people I was volunteering with
tremendously in terms of you know all
the legal fees and challenges is created
in many ways for their life in some
cases a lot of terrorist threats the
bigger issue is the obstruction in terms
of u.s. foreign policy the terrible
impact that this sat on possibilities in
terms of us-russia relations having
creating a better pathway for the world
that you know President Trump was
talking about during the campaign and so
I'm hoping you know there's going to be
a lot more of this this is just the tip
of the iceberg I think what we've seen
here a lot more coming out over the
weeks to come but a bigger thing is
coming in with the Helsinki summit and
I'm hoping that you know the quicker
that these the truth comes out the more
they'll be able to you know chart a a
better course for the future of our
country so we will be at the Helsinki
summit look forward to that quarter-page
thanks very much thanks Tucker